hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to this educational video on
trading order flow and you know what
I'll be talking about today is
absorption and you know there was a
great example from uh this past Friday
uh December uh was that December 9th if
you remember you know crude oil had been
selling off from around 72
um you know it was trading around the
7250 area most of the morning sold off
quite nicely down to 7008 you see the
low down here and then it sprang right
back up to 71 uh 60s and you know that
was about a dollar and a half move in a
relatively short period of time you're
talking from you know 111 up until about
uh you know call it 211 So within an
hour it rallied 150 150 ticks and it was
you know a very fast move up you can see
how you know these bars are getting
elongated and you know it's almost as if
buyers are tripping over themselves to
get back in the market get long in crude
oil
and you know in the order flow there
were signs when we were coming into this
low that you know what that this was
going to be the low now
let me just be clear right order flow is
not about predicting where the low is
going to come into place right we're not
going to try and predict that oh there's
a low here rather what you're doing with
order flow is letting the market give
you clues that we are forming a bottom
potentially okay then it's up to you as
a Trader to sort of put the pieces
together because I'm going to show you
the pieces we're going to compare some
of these uh you know these other lows to
the low that happened here around uh you
know the 110 to 115 period
versus you know these earlier lows right
why didn't the market you know rally off
this low right this is those this is the
PIN bar right all those you know trading
gurus oh you got that pin bar you got to
buy it well if you bought this you know
we went lower from 70 55 you know all
the way down to this you know this low
was 70 15. you know and we went even
lower right this pin bar failed you know
so what was so special about this low
that this low didn't have or this load
didn't have or even this low didn't have
or you know even going back a little
further here and here right you people
gonna say well you had a double bottom
here
um you know you got these long Wicks
okay well you base essentially had a
double bottom here you know Market did
rally I guess from 70 90 up to 71 you
know we call it 19. okay but about
um you know about 30 tick rally whereas
here is is 150 ticks okay so you know
let's let's go take a look you know
here's your other big pin bar right
everybody goes oh you gotta buy these
pin bars well if you bought this one
you know if you're lucky maybe you
scalped a few ticks out of it but most
likely you would have been stopped out
right if you bought this pin bar most
as well if you didn't you know honestly
you know this is a one minute crude oil
chart if you're buying this pin bar you
know almost immediately you know after
about five or ten minutes you can see
it's just going sideways you're not
getting the move that you're expecting
you know it's not something when you you
buy it and get longer than wait and wait
and wait and wait take a lot of heat and
then the market rally back up you know
if you have something like this which is
supposed to be bullish the move should
happen now right here it started to go
but it just turned around and selling
came back in and it sold off more so
let's take a look at the order flow here
so this was the low here at 1 uh 11 and
again we hit a double bottom here at 114
then the market started to Rally up okay
now
there are some things you know after we
make this low right again you know we're
not trying to predict the low right if
you're trying to predict the low here
you know you're wrong here you're wrong
here you're wrong here you're wrong here
you're wrong but you're waiting for the
order flow to sort of confirm that you
know what this is potentially the low
now at this low right that 1 11 Low 111
afternoon
you'll notice right a couple things you
know this point of control here at 70 10
you got these two bars with Point
control at the same level right it's
coming into liquidity 204 contracts
traded the first time
that you got into that low
that liquidity got removed from the
market market went back up to 70 26 then
the Market's coming back down to the low
again now you see a fresh bitter coming
into the market 154 contracts that's
nice to see because we know that there's
buying at these levels right at this you
know 70 10 level probably liquidity at
05 and obviously at the round number 70
even there's probably also going to be
liquidity there
now what was interesting as we're going
into these lows you see the big strong
negative Deltas here minus 110 minus 107
as you make that new low minus 374 as
you hit the low again it's minus 156 the
difference between this bar and this bar
obviously both negative Deltas this is a
red candle this is a green candle we got
a green candle with a strong negative
Delta and more importantly the max Delta
is zero so I know that by looking at
this candle looking at the delta
that I'm seeing some signs of absorption
why because I have this green candle and
I look at the footprint
you just look at it right I mean this is
the thing you know people think candles
reveal oh no they don't they don't
reveal the most important thing which is
volume right you got to look at the
volume where it's trading is it trading
on a bid or is it trading on the offer
but as this Market came back down to
test the low a buyer stepped up a buyer
came in to absorb that selling he
absorbed that selling got past it a
little bit you know traded 13 it traded
four
and then it started drifting back up
where is that continued selling it's not
there at least not in this bar the next
bar comes in you got a positive Delta
small 28 next bar minus 56 next bar
again smallish Delta of 18. you know
just because you have a Delta that's
small of like 18 doesn't mean that
nobody who's
buying or selling because the volume in
this bars is 538 you know this bar is
356 this bar is 682 I was just telling
you it's more or less evenly matched but
the real
giveaway that this move had something to
it
that not only did you have you know
buyers coming in lifting price higher
because for price to go higher you need
aggressive buyers you need people to be
lifting the offer but what what happened
in here
if you're watching the cumulative Delta
it's actually
getting more strong to the negative it
went from 17 minus 17
000 you know 520 to over here you got
minus seventeen thousand six hundred and
twenty cumulative Delta
is actually
still going down price is going up so
you have this Divergence between price
and cumulative Delta and what that means
is you have
Traders absorbing that selling
not only do you have that but you also
have obviously the aggressive buying to
help move price higher so when you're at
a low like you are here and you see
absorption coming and you see Traders
coming in to absorb that selling right
that's why you have green candle with
negative Delta green candle with
negative Delta right green candle with
you know small negative Delta okay so
but you can see the Delta okay this is
the cumulative Delta here this is you
know a Candlestick representation of
cumulative Delta you know a lot of
platforms have it
um you know programmed in their platform
already
and this is where it becomes very useful
right you're going into the low you hit
a low cumulative Delta is still going
down but price is moving up that's that
should have your attention
right and then obviously we see Delta
growing quite nicely we you know we're
going down here in the cumulative Delta
down down I think cumulative Delta he
starts seeing it go back up you see each
individual bar is quite strong 122 153
200 that's the Delta surge taking place
you know more and more aggressive buying
so what you had here is a combination of
absorption followed by strong aggressive
buying right as price was moving up now
compare that low
to this low okay we hit this low here
okay strong negative Delta okay we're at
the low that's what you expect to see
right you expect to see strong selling
because you're making a new low
then cumulative Delta more or less
ticks higher as price moves higher okay
that's what you're expecting to see you
don't see that's necessarily that sign
of absorption you're seeing the
aggressive trading but you'll notice
even though cumulative Delta
goes from you know minus seventeen
thousand you know 0.90 to minus 16
930 so you know it that was a couple
hundred Delta change what you're seeing
in here
right is cumulative Delta Rising but
price is just you know it did go up a
little bit I'm not saying Mark markets
railing but just more or less going
sideways right it does pick up here but
then after that it just goes sideways
not what you're expecting if you're
expecting this Market to move higher
right let's go back a little further
here right
you know this one actually look you know
potentially kind of bullish you know we
hit this new low here this is at 12 35
you had
negative Delta of minus 48 okay not that
strong but it's a green candle okay now
I like candles where you get that big
um sort of lower Wick right these green
candles you get there was strong selling
earlier in the bar it was minus 181 on
the Delta and it came back up to only
finish at minus 48.
I'd be looking for this next bar if this
next bar could start putting in some
positive Delta then again the next bar I
might look for that rally to happen
but it doesn't doesn't go any higher
just goes inside of the previous bar
which as you know
when you get a big handle and then the
next candle goes inside chances are the
Market's going to go sideways and it
does it actually goes inside inside
almost inside inside again you know it
just really contracts okay it's not
moving up off this low Deltas again
still negative more or less but you know
negative Smalls
um and then it comes down makes that new
low earlier
this was at 12 this move from you know
12 16 down to 12 20. new low strong
negative Delta minus 350 goes inside
inside breaks out makes a new low strong
negative Delta minus 453 again a new low
big strong negative Delta minus 42 small
green candle you know I've got these
selling imbalances right down here at
the bottom of this bar which sort of
lets me believe that
um you know maybe there's some stops
that got triggered down below 70 40
because the market stamped right back up
and sort of closed uh more or less where
it opened but you're left with that big
overhanging negative Delta on the green
candle okay well maybe maybe this move
is this move down
is over right there's some nice volumes
you know the resting liquidity here here
all right then the next bar that's where
you got to pay attention what's going to
happen in the next bar after the low if
it goes inside chances are we can still
go inside in the next bar in the next
bar or and just go sideways and that's
what we do go inside a little bit lower
or it's all inside this one bar here
over this next uh you know 10 minutes
over that actually before you break out
to that new low here
but you're not seeing anything really
bullish Happening Here in terms of the
delta in terms of the order flow you're
still seeing some selling coming in
but cumulative Delta is more or less
just you know going sideways
right it's starting to tick up a little
bit here as you can see but more or less
it's just it's just going sideways it's
not making new lows in cumulative Delta
this is the low here so it hasn't gone
below that but you know when you're
making new lows
what you expect to see is cumulative
Delta getting stronger to the negative
side right if it's just sort of going
sideways
you're not getting anything to go off of
right in terms of cumulative Delta
cumulative Delta is not necessarily a
tool that you can use to take trades I I
find it more useful to confirm trades I
confirm your idea of what's happening in
the market but just based off these lows
you know I'm always looking for a reason
to buy off a low I'm not trying to
predict that this is going to be the low
what I'm looking for is the market Give
Me A Sign please God give me a sign that
this is going to be the low I don't have
anything off any of these lows here
nothing here nothing here
nothing here nothing here it's not until
you get down here to this double bottom
and I see the selling right we're making
new lows in the cumulative Delta but
price
is rallying
that's my sign and then it just stands
out right in here in in the regular
Deltas where it just grows and grows and
grows over three bars right now you know
in our
new version of order flow straighter 6
we actually color These Bars when they
have bullish positive Deltas or negative
bearish deltas and even you know the
Delta divided by volume
um you know if it's above a certain
threshold it's bullish if it's below it
it's bearish so I'm gonna add here at
the low here and I'm seeing positive
strong positive Deltas here one here
here here here
right I'm seeing you know the Delta
volumes as being strong positives one
two three even you know because at this
low I might not be convinced here yet
right but by watching What's Happening
Here with this volume coming in out of
nowhere we just took out that low that
level of 70 10 rallied back up but now
that buyer comes back in yeah I'm
bidding 09 again for 150 or sorry 10 for
uh 150 okay so somebody with some Deep
Pockets just you know sticking their
neck out so to speak and bidding it
after you just made that low that's a
very positive sign that's what's giving
this bar this negative Delta of 156 if
this was just your regular volume you
know look at these volumes here mostly
it's you know 20 to 40. so if this would
say 30 you'd have a positive Delta in
this bar you know and it might get lost
in the
and all the action but you see that big
volume here 154
in an area that you just traded
that support
okay that's the clue That's The Power of
using a footprint that's going to help
you catch these moves right hopefully
you could catch it notice what's
happening as well in the cumulative
Delta and here you've seen this is a
Delta surge Delta is increasing over
consecutive bars so even I'm not saying
that you had gotten long off you know
here off this double bottom but
definitely when you're starting to get
into this area 70 55 for sure
that that low is in the rear view mirror
already right you you got to be thinking
that's the low of the day and get ready
because you know we could start rallying
and we Rally from you know this is that
area 55 in here
literally from you know one you know
call it hero you know 123 124 call 125.
even if you're getting in late you know
at 70.
boom 70 all the way up to you know to
40.
what is that it's a 70 Cent move in how
long
right you're talking here from you know
up to what 133
five was that six minutes
five minutes six minutes seven minutes
just by understanding what's happening
in the cumulative Delta what's happening
in the volume that's trading right
what's happening
um in terms of is there absorption
taking place in the market and you can
see that just by picking that up right
there if you're watching a footprint
all right you can see that 154 come in
there
all right so yeah again I hope you found
this video useful and again if you like
my videos be sure to like And subscribe
um I'm trying to get back on a regular
posting schedule so
you know ideally I want to get one up
every day sometimes I'll try and get two
up every once in a while as well in the
same day so again you know be sure to
like And subscribe and thanks for
watching my videos bye